dream Kardashian is proving to be a  social media star Luke - Christian a  hooker  just one day after blac Chyna and Rob  Kardashian welcomed their daughter the  proud parents created an Instagram  account for their baby girl Friday  she's already verified has a growing fan  base and is breaking the Internet at an  early age I guess here's dreams second  post showing China breastfeeding the  newborn caption it's bonding time with  mommy dream also made her snapchat  debuted the same day she was born  adorably rocking a flower crown with mom  well we think the newest Kardashian fits  right into the social media savvy family  we're excited for the new addition in my  family and in their family